PRESENTER: Historically, wheels
were made of metal or wood.
With the invention of
air-filled car tires
in the early part
of the 20th Century,
the ride was revolutionized.
The inflated rubber tires
could better absorb the bumps
on the road, and the
addition of tread
gave the invention
serious traction.
Car tires have come a long
way in the last century.
The modern summer tire
is made of 10 to 15
different components
which include
natural and synthetic
rubber, chemical additives,
and carbon black, a pigment.
Giant blenders mix these
ingredients under heat
and tremendous pressure.
There are various formulations
for different parts
of the tire.
In each case, the result
is gummy rubber dough
which machinery then rolls
into sheets to wait further
kneading and processing.
Polyester fabric unrolls into
a machine called a calender.
The calender is equipped with
rollers that apply warm rubber
to both sides of the fabric.
This produces a rubberized
fabric that will
be used to reinforce the tire.
This fabric ply is kneaded
because rubber alone isn't
sturdy enough to make a tire.
Numerous cotton cords now spin
off bobbins simultaneously.
Machinery pulls them onto
the warm rubberized fabric.
They land on a bit of
an angle and adhere.
This cording creates
channels that
provide pathways for venting
air during the actual tire
building.
Making rubber for
tread requires three
different rubber formulations.
Extruders shape the
three streams of rubber,
and then they enter a die
that forms them into one.
Many paint rollers apply
different colored stripes.
It's a coding system
for identification
of the ingredients
during processing.
To avoid tension, the system
creates slack in the feed.
A blade slices the
tread rubber to length.
Next, many steel cables uncoil
at once to make the bead--
the part of the tire that
gives it the strength it
needs to stay on the wheel rim.
Machinery arranges the cables
in the desired configuration
and encases them in rubber.
More equipment rolls the
bead material into hoops
sized to fit the wheel rim.
They're now ready
to build the tire.
Using a special rotating
drum, a worker arranges
the two bead hoops on it.
Next up is an airtight
piece of rubber
that will act as an inner tube
followed by the corded ply.
Inflated bladders roll
the rubber around the bead
on both sides and then retract.
A surfer applies side
walls to the beads.
Little rollers fold the
side walls over the beads.
This completes the inner
part or skeleton of the tire.
They assemble the
outer layer separately,
beginning with strips of rubber
embedded with steel cord.
The system wraps
this rubber around
a second tire-building drum.
Next up are narrow
strips of rubber ply.
The computerized
system winds them
with just the right amount of
tension for a graduated effect.
They're now ready for the
last layer, the tread rubber.
Machinery applies it to the ply.
It's time for the two tire
fabrications to become one.
A transfer ring
collects the assembly
and transfers it
to the inner part.
Compressed air inflates
the tire to shape it,
and all the sticky
layers adhere together.
The machine rolls the
edge of the tread rubber
over the side walls.
They now have what's known in
the industry as a green tire,
an uncured tire
without tread pattern.
Next, it's into a mold to
bake and shape the tire.
The two parts of the mold come
together like a waffle iron.
Inside, hot steamy bladders
expand to shape the tire
and transfer the
tread pattern to it.
This specific tread pattern
is designed for summer tires.
This cutout of a car tire
demonstrates how all the layers
have been fused together.
The time in the hot
pressurized mold
has caused the rubber to
vulcanize, a chemical reaction
that transforms it from a weak
and sticky substance to one
that's strong and elastic.
A worker trims excess rubber.
After final inspections
confirm the tire's shape is
uniform and
geometrically correct,
the tire is ready for shipment.
It's time for the
rubber to hit the road.